>> Laura: THE END OF THE IRAN
DEAL IS EVEN BIGGER NEWS IN
ISRAEL BELIEVE IT OR NOT THEN IT
IS HERE.
JOINING IS NOW EXCLUSIVELY TO
REACT TO TODAY'S EVENT IS
ISRAELI AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES.
MR. AMBASSADOR, THANKS FOR BEING
IN HERE TONIGHT.
THIS IS A WILD DAY.
THE GLOBALLY --
>> THE A GREAT DAY.
>> Laura: THE GLOBAL ELITE,
ONE AFTER THE OTHER CAME OUT,
EVEN SINCE MY SIT DOWN WITH JOHN
BOLTON, HILLARY CLINTON JUST
WAITING IRAN IS NOW MORE
DANGEROUS.
SHE SAID ANYONE WHO THINKS
BOMBING IS THE ANSWER IS
WOEFULLY MISINFORMED ET CETERA,
ET CETERA.
I DIDN'T PUT THE WHOLE THING UP
THERE.
JOHN BRENNAN, FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR, SIMULTANEOUSLY THE
PRESIDENT LIED ABOUT THE IRAN
NUKE DEAL, UNDERMINE GLOBAL
CONFIDENCE IN THE U.S.
COMMITMENT, ALIENATED OUR
ALLIES.
THIS IS A DANGER TO AMERICA'S
NATIONAL SECURITY.
OBAMA SAME THING, ONE AFTER THE
OTHER AFTER THE OTHER AND YOU
SAY?
>> ISRAEL DISAGREES AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT UNITES ISRAELIS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
THE PRIME MINISTER GAVE A FULL
THROATED ENDORSEMENT TO WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID TODAY.
THERE WERE PEOPLE THREE YEARS
AGO WHO SAID THIS DEAL WAS
ACTUALLY GOING TO PUSH MORE
FURTHER AWAY AND IF YOU DIDN'T
DO THIS DEAL THAN IT WAS GOING
TO BRING MORE CLOSER.
THE EXACT OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED.
WE ARGUED THEN THAT THIS DEAL,
BY GIVING ALL OF THESE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO IRAN WAS GOING TO
FUEL IRAN'S WAR MACHINE AND WE
WOULD SEE ITS EFFECTS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU HAVE
SEEN OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS
IN IRAQ, AND SYRIA, AND LEBANON,
IN YEMEN.
IRAN IS FAR MORE DANGEROUS TODAY
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL.
THE CHANCES OF WAR ARE MUCH
HIGHER BECAUSE OF HIS DEAL.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID TODAY
IS HE TOOK A DEAL THAT BASICALLY
PUTS US ALL ON CRUISE CONTROL
HEADING OVER A CLIFF BECAUSE IN
A FEW YEARS ALL OF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS WILL BE REMOVED AND
IRAN DOESN'T HAVE TO SNEAK IN OR
BREAKING TO THE NUCLEAR CLUB,
THEY CAN JUST WALK IN.
HE TURNED THE WHEEL.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S NOT
MORE CHALLENGES BUT AT LEAST WE
KNOW WE ARE NOT HEADING OFF A
CLIFF AND RIGHT NOW WHAT ISRAEL
IS DEALING WITH OUR ACUTE
SECURITY CHALLENGES THAT
ACTUALLY INCREASE IN THE WAKE OF
THE DEAL.
IT MIGHT BE THE PEOPLE IN
BRITAIN AND IN FRANCE AND IN
GERMANY WHO THINK THE WORLD IS
SAFE BUT THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
WERE THE GUINEA PIGS IN THIS
ARABS WHO CAME OUT BOTH --
>> Laura: THE SAUDIS CAME OUT
BIG TIME AND SUPPORT, OTHER ARAB
NATIONS.
>> THE EMIRATES GAVE A PUBLIC
ENDORSEMENT OF THIS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SEEN THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
AS I'VE SAID FOR YEARS, WHEN
ISRAELIS AND ARABS ARE ON THE
SAME PAGE, PEOPLE SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION.
WE WERE THE GUINEA PIGS IN THIS
EXPERIMENT.
IT HAS GONE VERY WRONG AND WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR MAKING THIS
COURAGEOUS DECISION TO SHIFT
COURSE AND WE HOPE THAT OTHER
PARTIES NOW WILL UNITE BEHIND
HIS LEADERSHIP AND ACTUALLY GET
A DEAL THAT WILL PREVENT IRAN
FROM EVER DEVELOPING.
>> Laura: ALL OF THESE
DEMOCRATS LIKE SCHUMER AND
MENENDEZ, ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
WHO WERE SAYING DON'T HOW ROTTEN
THE IRAN DEAL WAS WHEN OBAMA WAS
ABOUT TO ENTER INTO IT.
NOW YOU DON'T HEAR SO MUCH FROM
THEM.
BY THE WAY, I KNOW YOU ARE GOING
TO BE THRILLED TO HEAR THAT RT,
RUSSIAN TELEVISION WEBSITE IS
SAYING THE ISRAEL LOBBY IS
CALLING THE SHOTS IN TRUMP'S
ROLLBACK POLICY ON IRAN.
MAX BLUMENTHAL, WHO I KNOW YOU
KNOW WELL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO HAS BEEN
CAMPAIGNING FOR YEARS AGAINST
THIS DEAL, APPARENTLY YOU ARE
THE ONE CALLING THE SHOTS.
IT'S EITHER JOHN BOLTON CALLING
THE SHOTS WERE THE ISRAEL LOBBY
CALLING THE SHOTS EVEN THOUGH
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SINGLE-MINDEDLY FOCUSED ON THIS
ISSUE FOR YEARS.
>> IT'S BEEN NO SECRET WHAT
ISRAEL'S POSITION HAS BEEN ON
THIS DEAL.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL
CAME TO CONGRESS AND SPOKE UP
AGAINST THIS DEAL AND WHAT HE
SAID AT THE TIME, PEOPLE SHOULD
REMEMBER, IS THE DANGER OF THE
DEAL IS NOT THAT IRAN IS GOING
TO VIOLATE IT, IT'S THAT THEY
CAN KEEP THIS DEAL AND WALK INTO
AN ENTIRE NUCLEAR ARSENAL.
WHAT THE PRIME MINISTERS SHOWED